[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGELA GOSZ: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Angela Gosz.
And today, we're here to talk
about connected health care,
enabling secure entry points
into the cloud with Chrome.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we'll have Googlers on
standby waiting to answer them.
So let's get started.
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
Within health care and what
we shared this year at HIMSS18
is that Google Cloud's goal
is very much a reflection
of Google's overall mission.
Applying this mission
to health care
means using open standards
to help enable data sharing
and interactive collaboration
while also providing
a secure platform.
To kick things off today,
here's a brief video
to illustrate what
that might look like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- In business, there are
a lot of moving parts.
Google Cloud helps
you connect the dots.
Use Chromebooks with G
Suite to make communication
more open and productive.
Access real-time data from
Google Cloud Platform.
Keep inventory up to
date automatically.
Add smart chips to
your valuable products
to monitor location and
conditions in real time.
Get instant updates
from deskless workers
out in the field.
Reduce costs, improve
efficiency, and ensure security
with Remote Device Manager.
Streamline operations and stay
in control with connected tools
and services from Google Cloud.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANGELA GOSZ: Excellent.
So where you sit
in the ecosystem,
be it a care provider,
researcher, supporting staff,
or health care decision
maker, technology
is changing the way
health care is delivered.
Common priorities for digital
innovation among health care
systems, hospitals,
and care facilities
include improving the
wellness of the community
through improved
access to patient care,
be it retail clinic,
telehealth, home monitoring,
or other virtual
health care option.
Reducing the cost
and complexity of IT
and increasing
agility, particularly
in the face of budget and
funding uncertainties.
Supporting new health
care business models
by providing anytime, anywhere
access to patient information
via remote and
multi-channel access
to mobile and web applications.
Strengthening
protection and defense
of PHI and other
sensitive health details
by leveraging
information security
in the face of new and more
sophisticated cyber threats.
Improving the quality of patient
services and business decisions
through more and better use
of big data analytics and IoT.
Four key trends
transforming the industry
and driving the needs for those
priorities are as follows.
The ongoing need to reduce
costs in the delivery of care--
health care systems
around the world
are struggling to
deliver satisfactory care
in the face of budget cuts
and increasing demands
from an aging and growing
global population.
Workplace challenges
contributing to this need
are the time and
staff shortages.
As physicians are pressured
to deliver an increasing
number of preventative services,
follow guidelines, engage
in evidence-based practice, and
deliver patient-centered care
in managerially-driven
organizations,
they struggle with
how much control
they have over their own time.
According to the biannual
physician survey, only 14%
believe they have the time they
need to provide the highest
standards of care.
Additionally, the current
worldwide shortage
of physicians, nurses, and other
health workers is 7 million.
And the gap is widening.
Some doctors are looking
to leave the profession
amid burnout and low morale
due to regulatory and paperwork
burdens and a loss
of clinical autonomy,
according to the World
Health Organization.
Training can also be a factor.
The BGL Group reports
that approximately 40%
of employees who receive
poor job training
are likely to leave
their positions
within the first year.
The second trend
transforming the industry
is the increasing threat of
cyber attacks and data loss.
With growing concerns
about cybersecurity
and the loss of sensitive
information, this is changing.
And the risk of not
overhauling and moving forward
with new viable
technology solutions
is becoming the greater threat.
The Poneman Institute estimated
an average breach cost
of $3.5 million in 2017
with a 27% probability
that a US company
would experience
a breach in the next 24 months,
costing between $1.1 and $3.8
million.
If you multiply that
estimate per record cost
for a breach across
the industry,
multiple breaches
combined would potentially
cost hundreds of
millions of dollars.
The third key trend driving
transformation in health care
is higher service expectations
from digitally-savvy patients.
Today's digitally-savvy
patients expect
on-demand personalized service.
Digitalization and
the implementation
of mobile strategies
can no longer
be approached as an afterthought
in the delivery of care
and patient experience.
Mobile is becoming
ubiquitous in health care,
playing a significant role as
the industry continues to adopt
a patient-centered approach.
Health care leaders
are now seeking
to improve the patient
experience through tailoring
patient engagement
strategies to meet
the expectations of their
digitally-savvy patients.
One example of this
is the proliferation
of mobile devices
in health care,
as it helps to reduce
paperwork time by 60%
and increase patient
face time by 29%.
And the fourth key trend driving
transformation health care
is advancing disease
prediction and prevention
through insights and
machine learning.
From high-end diagnostic
imaging systems
that let doctors catch
deadly diseases like cancer
in their early stages
to voice recognition
systems in the operating room,
which help doctors get a better
view of parts of the
body while operating,
technology has made life easier
for both doctors and patients.
However, although AI is
a hot health care topic,
some haven't felt
ready, meaning it still
needs to be translated
into reality, especially
in an industry as
complex as health care.
Among the challenges
to widespread use
are the acceptance
of AI applications
in clinical practice,
difficulty leveraging
divergent personal network
devices and AI solutions,
and access to
quality training data
on AI applications and health
and gaps in data streams.
As health care moves beyond
the walls of the hospital,
so health care IT must move
beyond the data center.
The need to adopt digital tools
and develop new strategies
to change the way care
is delivered to patients
and residents may seem obvious.
But the health care
industry sometimes
lags behind others in
its use of technology.
It's not that health
care providers
don't want to try new,
innovative tools to support
better models.
But the risk of failure has
often been deemed too high.
The implementation of cloud
strategies and digitalization
can no longer be approached as
an afterthought in the delivery
of care and patient experience.
It will not only help
meet the needs of today's
digitally-savvy patients.
It also has a potential to
impact every aspect of care
delivery and
operations, enabling
more efficient
utilization of resources,
more time with patients
at the point of care,
and a more secure and
governed working model.
Like it has in other industries
and commercial enterprises,
cloud-based technology
will play a pivotal role
in overhauling health and
social care environments,
providing care professionals
with secure, mobile access
to information and resources
at the point of delivery
and opening up new ways
to collaborate and improve
the quality of patient care.
In a traditional
computing model,
you would bring data
to the individual.
Data sharing in that
model essentially
implies data copying.
Costs can be high
and unpredictable.
There are burdens associated
with installs, integrations,
and upgrades.
Data silos detract from
insights and correlation.
And software deployment
can be inflexible.
But in a cloud
computing model, you
bring individuals to the data.
In this model,
simplicity is king,
and users truly share data.
Costs for services
are predictable.
The focus is on business value,
not managing infrastructure.
There is a comprehensive,
patient-centric view.
And apps and compute
can be done anywhere.
Let's go back.
Sorry about that.
Google Cloud offers many tools
within its enterprise portfolio
to address health care's digital
priorities and the trends
driving digital transformation
that we just discussed.
With more than a
billion users leveraging
seven of those
products each month,
the solutions range from storage
and compute, machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
productivity and collaboration,
to the platform that
serves as a secure gateway
to the cloud, Chrome Enterprise.
Chrome Enterprise is a license
you activate to centrally
manage, enroll, deploy,
monitor, and secure Chrome
devices running Chrome OS.
The central management console
offers a host of features
to keep your organization
safe and enable your end users
to work smart, including
access to Enterprise app store
fronts, deep security
controls, 24 by 7 support,
as well as
integration with Cloud
and on-prem management tools.
For your business, the
platform is secure by design.
The platform leverages
comprehensive, AI-driven threat
detection and granular
policies to protect
your data and your
users, custom security
protocols for individuals
or groups of users,
and you can easily provision,
manage, and secure devices.
Lost or stolen devices can
be disabled within minutes.
With over 200
security policies that
may be applied to either
the user or the device,
granular and flexible controls
enable centralized fleet
management and updates.
This ensures compliance
of IT policies,
no matter which user
is accessing the device
or which device is being
accessed by the end user.
This drives value for
your organization.
Increase your
employees' productivity
by ensuring they spend less
time waiting for new updates.
Automatic managed updates
take place in the background
without getting in the way.
And without those distractions
that sometimes you
find in a local platform, users
can get more out of their day
because it is simplified
and centralized,
resulting in a 63% lower
administration cost overall.
Then for the end
user, the platform
means secure application access.
Whether it's a SaaS app,
virtual desktop environment,
or a favorite
Android application
available through Google
Play for Enterprise,
users have access
to all of their data
right from the Chrome launcher
in the bottom-left corner
of the screen.
The platform is built
for the cloud worker.
When you deploy Chrome
to your care team,
clinicians become untethered
from local storage
and are able to enter and
access patient records quickly
and collaborate with
the extended team.
And finally, while health care
has a unique set of challenges
to simultaneously
deliver and protect PHI,
workers still care about having
the state-of-the-art devices
and cool features
to get the job done.
With enterprise-grade hardware,
the good news is we have both.
In health care, security
is a top concern.
Chrome Enterprise extends
comprehensive security
with a multi-layered approach.
Each Chrome device arrives
encrypted out of the box
through hardware-backed
security and a TPM chip.
Verified boot of Chrome
OS uses the TPM chip
to ensure integrity
of the device
and tell if the OS
is genuine or not.
Tab sandboxing means each
web page in application
runs in its own restricted
environment, which
prevents against attacks
such as cross-site scripting.
When run in ephemeral
mode, browsing information
is not left behind on the device
because the profile is deleted
immediately after the last
browser window associated
with the profile is closed.
And with AI-driven
threat detection,
Safe Browsing reports over 1,000
instances of suspected malware
every minute by showing users
a warning message before they
visit potentially
dangerous sites
or download a harmful app.
And, again, with AI-driven
threat detection in Google Play
Protect, all apps
are automatically
scanned for malware before
and after you install them.
Then, regular
updates and patches
round out this
multi-layered approach.
Chrome OS gets an
update every six weeks,
with security patches rolling
out every two to three weeks.
And on top of all
of that, Google
hosts a bug bounty program.
Again, all of this
happens in the background
while an end user is at
work, meaning disruptions
are minimized and
uptime is maximized.
Once again, Chrome OS
becomes ready for health care
through the Chrome Enterprise
license, which unlocks
the central management console.
The granular controls from
the 200-plus security policies
allow you to customize
and create your end user's
experience, be it in
cloud worker or one device
to one end user assignment mode,
public session, or many users
to one device
assignment, or kiosk
mode, which extends a single
app on a device or displays
information through
digital signage.
The policies can be
extended per user
or per device based upon your
existing end user segmentation.
While the Chrome
Enterprise console
provides a
feature-rich solution,
we also recognize the
needs of health care
to support overall clinical
and business workloads as well
as legacy apps.
With that in mind, Google has
partnered with top UEM vendors,
such as VMware,
Citrix, IBM, and Cisco,
to extend flexible
EMM management options
and integrate Chrome
Enterprise seamlessly
with your existing environment.
We also offer IDP solutions,
including Google Cloud Identity
and Microsoft Active
Directory, to easily define
a wide range of
criteria and control
which types of websites,
apps, and extensions
can be accessed by users.
From an end-user
perspective, again,
workers care about having the
state-of-the-art device with
cool features and access to the
apps they need to get their job
done.
A variety of form factors are
available to match your needs,
from traditional clamshell
to convertible 2-in-1
with stylists as well as
Chromeboxes and Chromebases.
Hardware options include
the latest Intel processor
models with 8-plus gigs
of RAM, on-device storage,
10 hours of battery life,
and various builds from entry
to rugged to premium
to suit your use case.
Google works with
top OEM vendors,
including Samsung, Lenovo,
Acer, Asus, HP and Dell,
so you can continue working
with your favorite brand or OEM
of record.
Combining the
software, hardware,
and management platform
that we just discussed
is how Chrome Enterprise
enables the connected experience
in health care for staff,
back office administrators,
and patients alike.
Carers and patients
have better access
to information in real time.
Reliance on outdated
processes is
removed as you integrate
with legacy systems.
And tech-savvy patients are
served with premium devices.
Let's take a moment to discuss
each one in more detail.
According to the "Journal
of Medical Health
and Informatics,"
mobile devices can
help reduce
paperwork time by 60%
and increase patient
face time by 29%.
Mobilize and connect health
care staff with Chrome devices
and empower them to deliver
more seamless care experiences.
Virtualization allows users to
access customer clinical legacy
applications and
address data security.
Leading VDI solutions
from Citrix and VMware,
as well as other
providers, secure access
to natively-installed
applications.
And through the Chrome
Enterprise central management
console, enrollment on the
experience takes less than a
minute.
From a user perspective, free
up health care professionals
from fixed workstations
and provide them
with easy, mobile access to
the files and information
they need on the go, meaning
they can deliver the best care
and achieve more in their day.
Chrome OS is built fundamentally
to reduce downtime for workers.
Devices boot in under 10
seconds and come out of standby
in under three.
Additionally, Chrome
syncs apps, policies,
and preferences across devices
so that workers have continuity
and can pick up from
where they left off
across multiple
devices in a day,
be it an exam room, hallway,
medical cart, front desk,
or if using a loaner device.
And that same
encrypted cloud profile
which follows one user
across multiple devices
means that one device can be
easily shared by multiple users
while ensuring that their
day is set by the policies
that IT extends.
Either way, if you're
following the end user
or following the
device, all OS updates
are happening in the
background, meaning users never
experience downtime due
to update notifications.
Then, with that same
cloud-based profile,
staff can easily
communicate and coordinate
a single, consistent
care plan across a team
with the adoption of G Suite.
Moving along to our
second use case,
being the non-clinical or
back office administration,
according to Gartner and
the US Department of Labor,
the amount of time an
average employee spends
searching for documents
per year is 400 hours.
ESG predicts $1.97 million
in savings and benefits
over a three-year period
using Chrome Enterprise
on Chromebooks, including
63% lower administration
costs through improved
operational efficiency.
With a fast setup
and intuitive UI,
users can be productive in
minutes with Chrome devices.
By including
cloud-enabled devices,
information and files
are readily accessible,
allowing staff to move
away from paper documents,
reduce filing costs,
and free up space
in the office in the same
way that we discussed
with a clinical use case.
Chrome devices can replace or
integrate with legacy systems
by providing secure
access to virtualized
desktops and apps for back
office administrators as well.
Lost or stolen device?
No problem.
IT admins can shut down and
wipe all devices on a network
from a remote location,
barring unauthorized access.
Approximately 40% of employees
who receive poor job training
might leave their positions
within the first year.
You can improve onboarding
and education opportunities
with shared devices and
cloud-based resources.
Host training and instructional
videos easily utilizing
the familiar YouTube platform.
Or house custom training
apps with managed Google
Play and maintain control
over app development.
In shared device
public session mode,
any employee could securely
access the data and resources
they need on any
company-controlled Chrome
device at any
location, providing
a more time-efficient
and convenient process
to fit around staff.
Here again, individual
cloud profiles
allow employees to sign in
from any device and only access
the data they're
permitted to see.
And for our last use
case we'll examine today,
patients are increasingly
looking at health care options
with a consumer-driven mindset.
On-demand kiosks
enable health care
providers to build
more opportunities
for tech-driven
self-service and autonomy,
as well as reducing staff
administration time and manual
processes.
With Chrome Enterprise,
power interactive
self-service stations that
have a 61% lower device
costs in kiosk mode
compared to competitors.
Through the central
management console,
you may deploy single
or multiple apps
through kiosk mode to
ensure guests can only
access the content
you want them to see
and remotely manage Chrome
devices from anywhere
to control a
network of displays.
When configured in enrollment
type public session mode,
all local user data is
removed from the device
at the end of each session,
preventing unauthorized access
from anyone else.
This means that Chrome is
affordable, reliable, and
flexible device
platform that makes
digital signage practical
for one screen or 1,000.
With Chrome,
hospitals and clinics
can easily deliver information
and services in real time
to streamline operations and
enhance the patient and staff
experience.
On the patient side, use kiosks
to improve patient well-being
through digital signage and
informative communications.
Using distraction in
clinical environments
has been shown to
reduce perceptions
of pain, lower anxiety and
stress, and benefit clinicians
by creating a calmer
environment for them to work,
often resulting in
quicker treatment times.
Placing informative digital
screens in waiting areas
can help lower anxiety,
alleviate frustration,
and reduce the perceived
wait time by 35%.
In tandem with
Google's CMS partners,
create dynamic digital
messaging to greet
and communicate with patients
via personalized messages.
Secure public kiosks and provide
shorter wait times and a better
guess overall experience
by streamlining
the check-in process.
And they can also
enable patients to order
and request assistance, securely
browse the web, or stream
content for entertainment.
In summary, Chrome can help
in many aspects of your health
care organization,
from clinical workflow
to business operations.
For care providers, Chrome's
cloud-connected endpoint
simplifies and secures
access to critical apps.
Reduced complexity
and ease of use
means more time
caring for patients.
Fast boot times means quicker
access to clinical information.
Long battery life means more
flexibility and mobility.
For the patient, Chrome provides
personalized digital service
and more access to information.
And for businesses,
health care organizations
can save money, simplify
their IT, and manage risk.
To share an example of a
current customer leveraging
Google Cloud technologies
in health care,
Middlesex Hospital has embraced
an innovative computing
infrastructure.
More than 3,000 employees
throughout the health care
network now count on
G Suite, including
calendaring, scheduling,
email, instant messaging,
and websites, and
the browser that
powers them, Chrome, to easily
and powerfully collaborate
with one another.
The challenge they were facing
was that their legacy solution
was not fulfilling
requirements needed
to match their high patient
satisfaction ratings.
The solution-- after moving
to Chrome browser in 2010,
the hospital began
to use G Suite,
seeing quick uptake from staff.
And Chromebooks were then later
adopted for training purposes
to start.
And then the footprint
was expanded.
The benefits-- massive cost
savings on their software
licensing costs.
Legacy browsers and
health care applications
were still supported,
including SSO, VDI,
and their primary EHR,
because Chromebooks allowed
the hospital to virtualize
essential clinical applications
and support.
So that's a wrap on connected
endpoints and health care.
Thank you for joining us today.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. We will
be back in less than a minute.
Welcome back.
Now we're going to take a look
at the live Q&A that's come in
from the audience today.
So the first question is, how
is Chrome Enterprise licensed?
Chrome Enterprise is available
in either an annual license
or a perpetual license.
And typically, we would
encourage a customer
to start the conversation
either with a member of my team
or with their preferred
reseller partner.
OK.
What else?
Does Chrome Enterprise
require G Suite?
While Chrome and G Suite
work very well hand in hand,
and we would say that one
makes the other even more
useful and productive, G Suite
is not required to run Chrome.
And it looks like on
our next question,
which is, can I access Office
365 on Chrome, the answer
to that question--
similar.
Yes, you can access Office
365 through the Google Play
app, which is available,
again, through the console.
So you can just install your
office productivity apps
through the Google Play Store.
And then looks like we
have another question.
Can my clinical team use a
proximity card to log in?
Actually, yes.
So this is very popular, and
we get this question a lot
in health care.
In health care workflows,
badge tap and go--
I have a badge here at Google--
a clinician would come in.
They would badge tap in.
And they would get into
their session securely.
We do offer badge tap and
go with proximity cards
through our partner HealthCast.
And as we continue to
expand our relationships
with different manufacturers
and health care organizations
to make the solution even
better for our customers,
we hope to continue to
partner and integrate
more solutions that round
out health care workflows.
So it looks like that is the end
of the Q&A. So with that said,
thank you for watching.
Our next Cloud Air
will be on July 10.
[MUSIC PLAYING]